ARRIVED WE WILL CALL THE
WEDNESDAY JUNE NINETEENTH
MEETING OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
TO ORDER.
AND SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS BATES.
IT'S HERE MONNING ROTH WILK
PRESIDENT WILL CARE ATKINS HERE
ATKINS HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT OUR
COLLEAGUES OR SHORTLY ON THEIR
WAY.
OF COURSE IN THIS DAY IN TIME
THERE AND OTHER COMMITTEES BUT
ON THEIR WAY -- I WILL ATTEMPT
TO ENTERTAIN A CONSENT AGENDA.
ARE ON THE ITEMS ARE NOT THE
APPOINTEES TO APPEAR.
AND IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING I CAN
PROBABLY ASK FOR CONSENT
CALENDAR ON GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR.
ITEMS E. G..
EIGHT ITEM.
THREE ITEM FOUR THROUGH.
SEVEN WE GET THAT SO MOVED.
OKAY -- MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS BATES.
BATES I AM MONNING ROTH WILL HI.
ROTH AYE MON OF WILK I ATKINS I
CAN I AND WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN -- FOR SENATOR MINING -- I
WILL ALSO TAKE UP NOW GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE IS NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. TO DE.
OUR AND ASK IF THERE IS A MOTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
SENATORS BATES.
BATES NO MINING.
MONNING HI ROUGH ROUGH HI WILK.
ATKINSHI ATKINS AYE. THREE ONE
THREE TO ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
I WILL NOW ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
ITEM TWO HE TWO F. O. I'M SORRY
TO F..
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH A MAN
SECRETARY SENATORS BATES.
MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH AYE WILK.
WILK AYE ATKINS HI ATKINS AYE
THAT PASSES -- FOR ZERO CAN WE
GO BACK IN OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA WHICH IS. FOR
YOUR BENEFIT SENATOR MINING.
IT IS ITEM TO E. G. H. AND THEN
ITEMS.
THREE THREE SEVEN SENATOR
MONNING I THANK YOU SENATOR ZERO
FIVE ZERO THAT IS OUT I'D LED TO
OUR COLLEAGUES AND GUESTS KNOW
THAT.
BOTH SENATORS WERE RUNNING FROM
OTHER COMMITTEES.
NOW LET ME OUT WELCOME I TO THE
DYESS ARE.
GEN ENGINE OF THE YES I LIKE TO
SAY ALTHOUGH.
SHE ROMA WHO IS APPOINTED AS THE
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WELCOME.
I WILL -- INVITE YOU TO MAKE
SOME OPENING COMMENTS I
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE YOU WOULD
LIKE TO IN THOSE COMMENTS AND
THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT INTO.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
SENATORS.
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH OUR CHILDREN ATKINS A
MEMBERS.
OF THE RULES COMMITTEE WITH ME
TODAY ARE MY HUSBAND MICHAEL
ADDED.
MY FATHER DAVID THE KAHLER SURE
ROMA.
AND MY GRANDDAUGHTER ISABEL.
ANNA A FEW COLLEAGUES FROM THE
THE CPUC.
ALSO AS I CELEBRATE FORTY ONE
YEARS THIS MONTH.
OF PUBLIC SERVICE -- WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I AM DEEPLY
HONORED. TO BE APPOINTED BY
GIVEN YOU SOME OF THE
COMMISSIONER TO THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN TAKING
THIS POSITION I RECOGNIZE.
THE ENORMITY.
OF THE CHALLENGES FACED BY THE
PEW C. WILDFIRES PGA
BANKRUPTCIES SAFETY. TO THESE
CHALLENGES I BRING TWENTY YEARS
OF OUR ELECTRIC UTILITY
EXPERIENCE.
HAVING SERVED IN SELECTED
DIRECTOR AT THE STOCK BARREL
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT.
I BRING MY ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATORY EXPERIENCE FROM THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND MY
CLOTHES THE ADJUDICATORY QUALITY
LEGISLATIVE EXPERIENCE FROM THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD.
WHY PRIORITY IN FOCUS BRIEFLY
ARE ONE THAT CALIFORNIA'S HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE SERVICE WHETHER IT'S
LITERACY?
GAS WATER COMMUNICATIONS
TRANSPORTATION.
THE CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO MAKE
PROGRESS ON OUR CLIMATE CHANGE
GREENHOUSE GAS GOALS.
IN THAT ATTENTION IS PAID TO
THOSE WITH LESS MEANS WHETHER
LOW INCOME THIS ABLE
DISADVANTAGED.
IN ALL THESE EFFORTS TO SEEK
INNOVATION AND BE AGILE EMERGING
TRENDS AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE WELL I
LOOKED TO MY RIGHT AND OBVIOUSLY
A COMMITTEE IS GOING ON
ELSEWHERE SENATOR MINING LET ME
START WITH YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND ANY TO
APOLOGIZE.
FOR MY TARDINESS.
WELCOME ISSUE ROMAN LET ME START
BY.
CONGRATULATING YOU ON THIS
APPOINTMENT THANKING YOU FOR
YEAR CAREER OF PUBLIC SERVICE
IT'S REALLY QUITE IMPRESSIVE AND
MOST RECENTLY IN THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD WHICH WE HAD A CHANCE TO
TALK ABOUT A LITTLE BIT
YESTERDAY -- AS YOU MOVE INTO
THE PC POSITION IT.
AN INTERESTING TIME NOT JUST FOR
THE PC BUT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND HOW WERE YOU LOOKING AT YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY THE P. YOU SEE
ROLE -- WITH.
THE WILD FIRE CRISIS WE FACE
LAST YEAR AND WORKING WITH
UTILITIES PARTICULARLY IN THE
AREA.
OF THE PLAN TO POWER OUTAGES --
WHICH ON THE ONE HAND ARE
DESIGNED TO PROTECT AGAINST.
TRAGEDY BUT ON THE OTHER HAND
CREATING.
A POTENTIAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
RISKS WHAT WHAT IS THE UC'S ROLE
IN OVERSEEING THAT PROCESS.
THE PC HAS A FRONT AND CENTER
ROLE ABSOLUTELY ALL IN THE STATE
STATUTE JURISDICTION ONLY ALL
AND END IT WITH A HIGH DEGREE OF
RESPONSIBILITY AND SO IN MY FOUR
AND A HALF MONTHS.
WE HAVE VOTED ON THE OF POWER
SAFETY US SHUT OFF WE VOTED ON
THE WALL FOR MEDICATION PLANS.
IN TERMS OF WHAT ALL OF THE
UTILITIES NEED TO DO TO PREPARE
AS OUR CLIMATE ARE VEGETATION OR
FORCE HAVE CHANGED.
OF WE'VE ALSO OF AGAIN -- IT
HAVE ADOPTED -- NEVER HAD
REQUIREMENTS I'D FOR
COMMUNICATION THREE IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THAT ADVANCE COMMUNICATION.
ASEAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC LED THE
WAY A DOZEN YEARS AGO ON THIS
EFFORT AND WE'VE BUILT ON THAT.
LINE WE TAKE IT VERY SERIOUSLY
SAFETY RELIABILITY OF
AFFORDABILITY ALL OF THESE
THINGS GO INTO THE EQUATION.
A AND I IN THE FOR HALF MONTHS
I'VE BEEN AT THE PC I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY VOTE ON EACH OF
THESE ITEMS.
THANK YOU IN IN TERMS THAT
ADVANCE COMMUNICATION -- WHAT IS
THE UTILITY REQUIRED TO DO WITH
THE RESPECTIVE IDENTIFYING?
PEOPLE THAT MIGHT BE DISABLED OR
DEPENDENT ON ELECTRIC IS
SUPPORTED BREATHING APPARATUS OR
OTHER TYPES OF LIFE SUPPORT.
A YES A SO THERE IT IS A
REQUIREMENT FOR THE TWENTY FOUR
HOURS IF NOT FORTY HOURS IN
ADVANCE.
EACH UTILITY HOUSE OF A A
KNOWLEDGE OF THE FOLKS ARE ALL
IN THEIR MEDICAL RATES WHO ARE
LIFE SUPPORT ALSO OF COURSE
HOSPITALS.
A AND SERVE WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEPENDENT UPON LECTURES HE FOR
FOR LIFE AND DEATH FRANKLY.
US AND THERE IS A REQUIREMENT
FOR THAT ADVANCE NOTIFICATION
INCLUDING KNOCKING ON DOORS.
THANK YOU.
WHEN WE TALKED ALSO ABOUT THE DE
COMMISSIONING OF DIABLO NUCLEAR
FACILITY -- THAT SOME PART OF MY
DISTRICT AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF EFFORT TO TRY.
TO MINIMIZE BOTH THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS BUT PROTECTING.
SAFETY.
AS A PRIMARY CONCERN.
THE FROM YOUR POSITION AS A PC
COMMISSIONER.
ONGOING OVERSIGHT OF THAT DE
COMMISSIONING AND IS THERE ANY
ANTICIPATED.
ADVERSE IMPACT BY THE BECAUSE BY
THE BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDINGS OF P.
JEANNIE.
AGAIN THE BANKRUPTCY IS MAKING
ITS WAY THROUGH THE FEDERAL
COURT -- FROM MY VANTAGE POINT
LOOKING AHEAD OF THE LANDSCAPE.
OF THEIR OUR CORE VALUES AT PLAY.
IN THE BANKRUPTCY TOWARDS
PROVIDING FOR THAT
SUSTAINABILITY RELIABLY WHETHER
IT'S A DIABLO CANYON OR THROUGH
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM AT P. JEANNIE.
AND I AM KEENLY AWARE OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT FOR THE
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT HAVING LIVED
THROUGH THE DE COMMISSIONING OF
THE RANGE OF SEIKO NUCLEAR POWER
PLANT HERE AND SAKURA COUNTY.
DID SHARE SOME OF THAT
EXPERIENCE WHICH I APPRECIATE.
SOME OF YOUR PAST.
WORK WITH WITH SOME --
DEFINITELY WAS ALSO -- IN
ADVANCE LEARNING CURVE FOR THIS
JOB I THINK SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LET ME
ADD -- TO MY CONGRATULATIONS
MISTER ON MATH.
AND RECOGNITION -- OF YOUR
INCREDIBLE POWER YEARS OF PUBLIC
SERVICE AND MANY MORE LEVELS.
WE HAD A VERY -- GOOD GOOD
CONVERSATION BACK AND FORTH IN
MY OFFICE ON ISSUES THAT ARE
VERY IMPORTANT CERTAINLY TO THE
RATE PAYERS AND IN MY DISTRICT
ONE BEING SANTA NO FREE AND
RELIABILITY AND ON THE OTHER ONE
UNFORTUNATELY IS THE HIGH USAGE
CHARGE.
AND ON THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY OFTEN CONCERNING ON IF NOT
STRONG OPPOSITION.
WITH C. U. P. R. C. P. C. U. P.
TURNING DOWN NOW THE REQUEST.
FOR RELIEF FROM THE HIGH USAGE
CHARGE AND UNFORTUNATELY ON THE
SHARON I DID HAVE A NO VOTE ON
OUT I'VE GOTTEN A LOT OF INPUT
ON VERY VERY SIGNIFICANT.
TO HOW THE RATE PAYERS AYE SHE
IS COMMITTED BY THE WAY TO BE
WORKING ON THAT BECAUSE WE ALSO
HAVE A VERY EXTENDED.
A TIME OF USAGE ON TOP OF THAT
OUT TO OURS IS ABOUT FOUR HOURS
FIVE HOURS SO I AM NOT SURE TO
FINISH FROM A TODAY I WOULD NOT
BE SUPPORTING HER.
BUT SHE HAS MADE MANY MANY --
COMMITMENTS AND PLEDGES TO BE
TAKING A LONG HARD LOOK AS SHE
EXTENDS HER SERVICE ON THE P. UC
ODD TO ADDRESS THIS REPAIR
PROBLEM THAT IS BECOMING I THINK.
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR MANY
PEOPLE NOT JUST IN MY DISTRICT
BUT THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THAT I I WANTED TO LET HER KNOW
THAT I AM VERY IMPRESSED WITH
WHAT SHE BRINGS TO THIS
COMMISSION.
AND I HAVE HIGH HOPES THAT SHE'S
GOING TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE BUT
TO REFLECT THE NEEDS IN MY
DISTRICT AND CERTAINLY THE
RESPONSES I'VE RECEIVED FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS.
AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL AND BY
THE WAY WE SHARE THAT BECAUSE
SHE WAS IN A SIMILAR POSITION ON
SMUD.
SO I WITHOUT TERM
CONGRATULATIONS BUT I WILL NOT
SUPPORT TODAY BUT CERTAINLY I'LL
BE WATCHING AND I KNOW WE
DECIDED TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
GOING FORWARD. FOR THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR SERVICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS I'M A WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR APPOINTMENT
TODAY -- CAN I GIVE YOU A LOT OF
STUFF TO DO SIGNED OVER.
OCU LATER WHICH I READ I REALLY
APPRECIATE HOW A TEN OF YOU ARE.
SO WE'RE NOT DOING IT THIS YEAR
I THINK BECAUSE YOU GUYS ALREADY
HAVE YOUR HANDS FULL BUT OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS THERE'S BEEN
ANY NUMBER OF LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS TO REFORM -- THE PC AS
YOU KNOW IS.
FIRST CAN I THINK ONLINE.
NINE NINETEEN ELEVEN AND YOU
KNOW FROM A LAY PERSON'S
PERSPECTIVE IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT
OF IT IS EVEN THOUGH IT'S
IMPORTANT SIDELOAD.
AND SO NOW I SINCE YOU'RE COMING
WITH FRESH EYES I JUST WANT TO
KNOW WHAT YOUR INITIAL THOUGHTS
ARE IN TERMS.
TO IS THAT PORTFOLIO TOO BROAD
OR AYE AYE ULTIMATELY I KNOW WE
MAKE THE DECISION BUT CERTAINLY
<c.red>AVING INPUT FROM SOMEBODY</c>
THAT'S ON THE FRONT LINES TO BE
HELPFUL SO.
I'M JUST INTERESTED IN IN CAN
YOU GUYS BE AFFECTED WITH ALL
THE THINGS YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE.
FOR THEY'RE ALSO SILOS SO I JUST
OPEN ENDED.
WHAT THANK YOU SENATOR OF?
AS WE DISCUSSED YESTERDAY AND I
I HAVE WORN HIGH OF MONTHS OF
EXPERIENCE -- AND WHAT I DO SEE
IS THAT.
WHETHER IT'S WATER GAS
ELECTRICITY.
THE COMMUNICATIONS AND
TRANSPORTATION.
THESE ARE REGULATED UTILITIES.
THERE ARE LIKE TYPE ATTRIBUTES
IN EACH ARE ALSO UNIQUE --
ASPECTS TO EACH OF WHAT I SEE IS.
PGA BANKRUPTCY IS WERE FOCUSED
ON WELFARE.
THE STAFF ARE ALL HANDS ON DECK
CAN YOU TO MOVE THE NEEDLE
FORWARD.
ON WHEN THESE THESE BE DONE
WHETHER IT'S WATER JUST --
CONSOLIDATIONS OR WHAT HAVE YOU --
AND SO OF I'VE BEEN ABLE TO VOTE
ON QUITE A FEW ITEMS VERY
DIVERSE.
I AND WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS
THAT.
WHAT I'VE SEEN OF THE SERVICE
THEY ARE VERY COMMITTED TO
WORKING VERY HARD INDEED AT THE
END OF THE DAY IT IS UP TO YOU
AND THE LOOK AT THE GOVERNOR?
IF YOU WANT US TO HAVE MORE.
OR LESS JURISDICTION WHAT I SAY
IS THAT EVERYONE IS WORKING VERY
HARD ON ALL SECTORS THAT WERE
RESPONSIBLE [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN -- WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC BUT AS I
DO THAT I I APPRECIATE SO MUCH
YOUR TIME YESTERDAY.
I TO GO OVER -- REALLY I THERE'S
SO MUCH UNDER THE JURISDICTION I
THINK IS THE VICE CHAIRMAN.
ALLUDED TO THAT IS SO IMPORTANT
AND NOW MORE THAN EVER WE REALLY
NEED YOUR EXPERTISE AND I YOU
KNOW I THIS COULD BE A CLOSING
COMMENT.
BUT I I INTEND TO SUPPORT YOU
AND YOUR FOR DECADES OF
EXPERIENCE ARE REALLY MORE
CRITICAL NOW THAN EVER FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS WE LOOK AT ALL THAT'S BEFORE
US SO -- I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT WE NEED -- WE NEED THE
EXPERTISE WE NEED SOMEONE THAT'S
WILLING TO BE COURAGEOUS AND
MAYBE -- I TAKE STAND SAID DON'T
SEEM AS POPULAR I WANT SOMEONE
THAT UNDERSTANDS THE ISSUES THE
FINANCING AS WELL AS THE THE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF WHAT THE
CPUC DOES SO -- HAVING SAID THAT
I WANT TO AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE I'M SURE SENATOR ROTH WILL
BE BACK BUT I I KNOW HE
EXPRESSED ARE -- A CONFIDENCE AS
WELL BUT WE HAVE TIME WE'LL GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
THEN IF I WILL OUT OF ORDER IF
HE WANTS TO SAY SOMETHING WHEN
HE COMES BACK ALLOW HIM THAT
COURTESY.
I GIVEN EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING
ON TODAY OUT LEGISLATIVELY.
I'M GONNA ASK MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF MR ROMA TO STEP FORWARD.
GIVE ME YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU
REPRESENT AND VERY BRIEF
COMMENTS WELCOME KEEP IT
INTERESTING BIG WITH HER AND
READ MRS IS FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT.
OUR ENGINEERS OF NON GENEVIEVE
FOR MANY YEARS BACK FOR AIRPORT
TIME.
VERY CONFIDENT SHE'S GONNA DO A
GREAT JOB THERE TIONS EVERYWHERE
ELSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
ATWATER THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION WE BELIEVE
THAT MISS ROMANS TWENTY YEARS AS
A SMALL BORE MEMBER WILL BE A
GREAT ASSET TO THE PC WE
SUPPORTER CONFIRMATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON --
JC FROM THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS APPOINTMENT.
WE HAVE A LONG RELATIONSHIP WITH
MISTER ON MY FROM HER WORK --
WITH SMUD AND WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE HER STRONG.
KNOWLEDGE OF ENERGY POLICY
ADDITIONALLY HER WORK WITH AYLER
BE DEMONSTRATES HER SUPPORT OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF A US SKILLED
AND A WORK FORCE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI TIFFANY FAN BEHALF OF GENERAL
MOTORS IN SUPPORT ALSO ON BEHALF
OF CAL CCA IN SUPPORT AND AND
SEE CLEAN ENERGY IT'S PART THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEING NONE I I WILL GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR SENATOR
ROTH -- SO THAT HE CAN BUT WHEN
HE RETURNS -- I DO THANK YOU
SENATOR A MOTION BY THE GOOD
SENATOR CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BATES.
BATES NOW MONNING MONNING AYE
ROTH.
WILK HI WELCOME AYE ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE.
THAT IS THREE TO ONE AND THE
ROLE WILL REMAIN OPEN BUT THAT
IS ENOUGH FOR CONFIRMATION
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK.
YOU.
WE WILL TRANSITION NOW TO A
FAMILIAR FACE -- FOR THE STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD LET ME WELCOME
BACK MONA PASCAL ROGERS.
IT IS GREAT TO SEE YOU ON THAT
SIDE OF THE TABLE -- AND WE'RE
SO PLEASED TO SEE YOU -- I THINK
YOU KNOW THE THE ORDER OF THINGS
INTRODUCE WHO WHO IS HERE TO
SUPPORT YOU.
MAKE YOUR OPENING COMMENTS AND
THEN WE'LL GET RIGHT INTO IT
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM PRETEND
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE THE
THREE MOST IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN
MY LIFE MY HUSBAND.
CHRIS ABOUT MY MOM OKAY WANT TO
MAKE I WANT TO MAKE SURE I SEE
WHERE FOLKS ARE.
AS PEOPLE ARE EXITING MY HUSBAND
CHRIS WELCOME CONNIE.
AND MY SISTER GIGI.
IT'S VERY GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL
AGAIN [inaudible]
HOW?
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH
YOU TODAY I WANT TO THINK OF IT
THE GOVERNOR THE GOVERNOR
NEWSOME AND GOVERNOR BROWN AND
AND O'LEARY FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SERVE ON THE STATE PERSONNEL
BOARD I AM HUMBLED.
AND HONORED -- I'M NOT SURE IF
YOU SAW BUT JUST MINUTES AGO A
PRESS RELEASE JUST WENT OUT
ABOUT ME LEAVING THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE -- JUST TODAY ONE TWENTY
NINE SO I WAX ONLY TIME IT.
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE YOU SAW
THAT -- YOU KNOW I'VE HAD THE
BEST JOB FOR FOR EIGHT AND A
HALF YEARS WORKING WITH A TEAM
THAT RECRUITED.
PEOPLE FROM ACROSS THE STATE.
THAT LOOKS AND REFLECT THE
GORGEOUS CALIFORNIA MOSAIC BUT
WE'VE DONE THAT AND REACHED OUT
TO PEOPLE PARTICULARLY PEOPLE
WHO.
DIDN'T THINK THEY COULD SERVE IN
A LEADERSHIP POSITION AND PROUD
OF THE THREE OVER THREE THOUSAND
PEOPLE TO FULL TIME POSITIONS ON
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS.
THE LESSONS THAT I'VE LEARNED
THEIR OF ABOUT DEMYSTIFYING A
PROCESS ABOUT REACHING OUT ABOUT
EXPLAINING THE PROCESS.
OF IS THE SAME ENERGY AND
CREATIVITY THAT I'D LIKE TO BE
BRING TO THE STATE PERSONNEL
BOARD.
YOU KNOW OUR JOB IS.
TO ENSURE A RECRUITMENT AND THAT
THE APPLICATION PROCESS IS
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL.
AND THE POLICIES ARE FOLLOWED
BUT I'D I DO RECOGNIZE THAT NOT.
ONE IS NOT WHEN PAT THAT WAY TO
REACH PEOPLE AND I I HOPE --
THAT BEING ON THIS BOARD I CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH KELLY CHAR
AND YOU ALL AND SISTER AGENCIES.
TO TO CONTINUE TO RECRUIT FOR
THAT NEXT GENERATION OF LEADERS
[inaudible]
YOU.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
SENATOR MINING I'M GONNA START
WITH YOU AGAIN.
MADAM CHAIR.
CAN THEM.
MISS A SCHOOL ARCHERS IT'S GREAT
TO SEE YOU HERE AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE THAT JUST ENDED
TWENTY MINUTES AGO AND AND NOW
SIGNING UP FOR ANOTHER.
IN IS PART OF YEAR.
REST OF RESUME IN SERVICE TO
CALIFORNIA I WAS LIKE TO FOCUS
ON FORMER LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
ACTING LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR THAT
WAS ONE OF THE OFFICES YOU HELD --
WE HAD A GOOD CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY.
I JUST THOUGHT I WOULD ASK CAME
IN OPEN QUESTION OF WHAT YOU SEE
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES BEING
MOVING INTO THIS POSITION IN.
ANY PERSONAL GOALS OR OBJECTIVES
SHE MIGHT HAVE GIVEN WHAT YOU'VE
LEARNED ABOUT THE STATE OF THE
PERSONAL BOARD JUST IN A FEW
MONTHS THAT I'VE BEEN THERE WERE
YOU KNOW WE I'VE SEEN SOME
TRENDS IN SOME OF THE CASES THAT
HAVE COME BEFORE US.
AN OF RESPECTFULLY I THINK THAT
ALL OF UR DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES I THINK ALL OF US NEED
TO REFRESH ON POLICY AND
PROCEDURES BECAUSE WHEN YOU
NOTICE THE SAME TYPES OF
MISTAKES WHEN IT COMES.
TO DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS YOU KNOW
IT IT IT JUST IT MEANS THAT YES
WE NEED TO HEAR THESE CASES BUT
WE ALSO WHAT I NEED AS A BOARD
NEEDS SUPPORT.
SB STAFF TO GO TO THESE
DEPARTMENTS TALK TO THE
DIRECTORS THE HR DIRECTORS BUT
THE THE SECRETARIES AS WELL AS
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. TO SAY
YOU KNOW THERE.
LET'S REFRESH AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S AN ON GOING LIFE
CHALLENGE BUT I DO I DO SEE THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE I REALLY.
I ALSO WANT.
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A LOT OF
DIFFERENT AVENUES FOR RECRUITING
RECRUITING SHOULDN'T BE JUST
TAKING.
THE TEST ONLINE IT SHOULD BE AS
MANY DEPARTMENTS IN A LOT OF
AGENCIES ARE DOING GOING OUT TO
THE COMMUNITY AND ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY
CAN.
YOU KNOW BE AT NEXT GEN OF
LEADERS AND STATE SERVICE.
SO THAT TAKES A LOT OF
COMMUNICATION WORK I KNOW IT'S
HARD BUT IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
BUY IN FROM THE LEADERSHIP.
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
AND I THINK THAT OUT REACH TIES
IN TO THE SHARE WITH ME THIS
STATISTIC OF HOW MANY PEOPLE
WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR RETIREMENT
A HIGH PERCENTAGE AND FORTY FIVE
YEARS AND I'M ONE OF ALL.
RIGHT.
SO IN THAT DOES REQUIRE
CONSCIOUS.
INTENTIONAL THAT REACH TO TO
RECRUIT THAT NEXT GENERATION
RIGHT AND AND AND AND
INFORMATION TRANSFER RIGHT SO
HOW DO YOU BRING ON PEOPLE NOW
BEFORE THE THIS MASS EXODUS OF
RETIREES.
AND I THINK WE REALLY SHOULD
CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT THAT I
THINK THE STAFF IS DOING A GREAT
JOB ABOUT THINKING OUTSIDE OF
THE BOX.
I THINK WE JUST NEED TO KEEP
HAVING CONVERSATIONS ESPECIALLY
WITH YOUR CONSTITUENTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE YOU KNOW WE'RE
ADDRESSING IN WOMEN'S ISSUES.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH NOW BE
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR APPOINTMENT
YOUR CONFIRMATION TODAY AND
AGAIN I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
SERVING THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
NOTHING MORE THAT'S IT THAT'S IT.
I'M TRYING TO LIKE RELATED --
CONGRATULATIONS I ACTUALLY DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS -- I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO SERVE AS SERVE
WELL SO SINCE THE CHURCH OUT A
COUPLE OF THE MEMBERS SHOT THIS
MOVE TO THOSE IN SUPPORT.
AND PLEASE FEEL YOU CAN
ARTICULATE AS LONG AS YOU LIKE.
NEVER GONNA HAPPEN EVER AGAIN SO --
ABRASIVE.
I ONLY HAVE FORTY FIVE MINUTES
TO COMMENTS ABOUT MONA -- TERRY
BRENNAN BEHALF MASS YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA -- WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORTER THIS NOMINATION AND
SUPPORT TO CONFIRMATION -- I'VE
KNOWN MONNING.
FOR COUPLE OF DECADES NOW AND
IT'S BEEN MY PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH HER A FEW WIKIPEDIA
CONSUMMATE PUBLIC SERVANT.
IT SHOULD HAVE HER PICTURE THERE.
AND I SAY THAT HAVING KNOWN SHE
SAID NO TO BE MORE THAN ANYBODY
ON THIS DAY AT SEA INCLUDING YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND DONE IT.
WITH GRACE CLASS AND
PROFESSIONALISM.
SO WHERE INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
STEVE BAKER WITH THEIR
NECESSITIES FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT.
MON IS GREAT WE LOVER SUPPORTER
CONFIRMATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN A MEMBERS OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE CHRISTY VELMA WE
HAVE A CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
I WAS A BABY LOBBYIST WHEN I MET
MONA.
AS SHE WAS KIND AND GENTLE TO ME --
BUT ALSO TAUGHT ME A LOT ABOUT A
GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC SERVICE
AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL.
FOR THE RELATIONSHIP THAT I HAVE
WITH HER BUT ALSO CAN ONLY USE
ONE WORD SHE IS PHENOMENAL.
SHE'S FROM PHENOMENAL TO ALL
PARTIES AND SO I AM PROUD TO
STAND HERE AND REQUEST YOUR
CONFIRMATION.
MR VICE CHAIRPERSON COMMITTEE
BRIAN NELSON ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
OUR WORKERS ARE DELIGHTED -- TO
SEE THIS OP IN THE CONFIRMATION
WE'RE SUPPOSED BY OBVIOUSLY
INCREDIBLY SUPPORTIVE OF MONA
SHE HAS BEEN NOTHING MORE THAN.
OF FOR FAR UNION AN ASSET
DEALING WITH OUR STATE EMPLOYEES
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES ANY
ISSUES THAT HAVE COME UP DURING
HER OUR PREVIOUS POST SO WE ARE --
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
CONFIRMATION AN WITHIN THE
ENCOURAGE YOU ALL -- TO MOVE
FORWARD IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF
STATE WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
MISSION TURNED SENATORS COULD BE
PRESENTED WITH ALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS SO WE COULDN'T BE
HAPPIER WITH THIS APPOINTMENT
MONA IS A WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY SHE'S VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND DELIBERATE OF AND
SHE COMES DRUM CONCLUSIONS I I
THINK WE WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHICH CHAIR MEMBERS PACMAN
WITHIN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HIGH PATROLMAN IN
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS.
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
NOMINATION AND CONFIRMATION
SHE'S BEEN AMAZING WHERE SHE'S
AT AND THIS WILL BE NO DIFFERENT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AT PERRYS WITH
SEIU LOCAL ONE THOUSAND
REPRESENTING NINETY SIX THOUSAND
STATE EMPLOYEES I WON'T
NECESSARILY REITERATE WHAT
EVERYONE ELSE IS ALWAYS HAS
ALREADY SAID BUT THE STATE
EMPLOYEES ARE VERY -- HAPPY THAT
MONA IS GOING TO BE ON THE STATE
PERSONAL BOARD VERY EXCITED --
TO TO SUPPORT HER CONFIRMATION
AND ALSO JUST PERSONALLY -- MONA
HAS BEEN SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN A
MENTOR TO ME BEING NEW TO
CALIFORNIA GO RED SOX -- BEING
NEW TO CALIFORNIA ABOUT TEN
YEARS AGO MONA IS WONDERFUL SO
VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE THANK YOU.
YOU CAN COME LOBBY MY OFFICE ANY
TIME BECAUSE I'M PRO RED SOX.
TO MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ALBERTA TO RECALL
BEHALF OF NOT A FOR A COMMERCIAL
WORKERS IS THAT CLOSE TO
PROVISIONAL REALIZATIONS AND
CALIFORNIA APPLICANT.
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
I JUST WANT TO SAY IS --
ABNORMAL TO FOR A FEW YEARS AS
WELL -- THE CONSUMMATE
PROFESSIONAL THE CONSUMMATE
PUBLIC SERVANT.
I THINK THAT OF WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IN IN THESE
APARTMENTS IN OFFICE TO THE
POLITICAL APPOINTMENTS WOULD BE
ON THAT.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR PEOPLE THAT
THE BEST SINCE THE STATE OF MIND
THEY'RE GONNA BE DILIGENT THIRD
AND FOURTH RIGHT.
THE GOING TO BE BEYOND REPROACH
AT THE CON DISAPPOINTMENT FITS
THE BILL ON ALL MARKS.
PRETTY SOON AFTER TO PLEASE
CONFIRM THE APPOINTMENT THANK
YOU.
A TO MOVE IT UP A LITTLE BIT.
CHAIR COMMITTEE STAFF DOCTOR
MICHAEL MERRY IN FULL.
SUPPORT OF DISAPPOINTMENT --
I'VE KNOWN HER FOR ALMOST NINE
YEARS AND SEEING HER AS A MODEL
IN THE COMMUNITY ALSO AT THE
STATE LEVEL HAS BEEN ON ON A
PLEASURE AND I FULLY SUPPORT
THAT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAITLIN
VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS APPOINTMENT I
BELIEVE WITH SUPPORT HER FOR
VIRTUALLY ANY APPOINTMENT AS SHE
IS ONE OF THE HARDEST WORKING.
MOST COMPETENT KINDEST OF
PROFESSIONALS THAT WE HAVE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
SOMEONE WHO IS ALWAYS REACHING
OUT TO AND SUPPORTING WOMEN.
THE THING UP OTHER WOMEN LOOKING
OUT FOR WORKING PEOPLE -- AND
FOR THE BEST INTERESTS OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
SEE HER ANYWHERE AND HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS APPOINTMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON A ROBBIE AVALON
THE DEPUTY SECRETARY OF STATE
YOU'RE ON BEHALF OF SECRETARY
STATE OUT EXPEDIA.
IN FULL SUPPORT OF MONA AND ALSO
MYSELF PERSONALLY.
SHE HAS BEEN -- BUT SUCH A HERO
FOR US AND FOR THE FILIPINO
COMMUNITY AND FOR YOUNG WOMEN
WHO SHE'S BEEN MENTORS WITH FOR
SO LONG SO.
CHEERFUL SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN I SUPPRESS IT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
ON BEHALF OF THE TWO AND FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES WE'RE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORTER.
A CONFIRMATION AN PERSONALLY
ALSO WHAT IS THAT IS NOT JUST
THE FILIPINO COMMUNITY THAT HAS
BENEFIT FROM A LEADERSHIP IS A
TIRE API COMMUNITY.
FROM SO MANY DIFFERENT ASPECTS
OF THE CAREER HERE IN THE
CAPITAL.
CAN'T THINK OF A BETTER
CANDIDATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BY THE WAY YOUR FORMER BOSS OF
TWENTY FIVE MINUTES AGO SAYS TO
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST.
HI.
SO PLEASE FORGIVE ME FOR
STEPPING ASIDE I WOULDN'T DO IT
FOR MOST -- BUT IT WITH THAT --
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I AM HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING MADAM
SECRETARY.
SENATORS BATES.
MONNING MONNING AYE ROTH.
WILK HI WILK AYE ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE AND WE OF COURSE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN TO TO GET
OTHER VOTES AND BUT THAT IS
ENOUGH TO CEMENT THE DEAL
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE
.
AND LET'S SEE FOR THE GRAND
FINALE TODAY -- LET ME WELCOME
FORWARD ARE A THIRD AND FINAL
APPOINTEE. TO APPEAR TODAY MR
LIEU PAULSON LOUIS PAULSON WHO
IS A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD.
SO AS PEOPLE ARE EXITING WILL
GIVE IT A MINUTE AND LET YOU GET
READY -- TO TO GO INTRODUCE
ANYBODY THAT YOU HAVE WITH YOU
HERE TODAY THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
AND THEN.
OPENING COMMENTS AND WE'LL GET
RIGHT INTO IT THE MAN PRO TEM I
AM ALSO SCORING OPENING COMMENTS --
CONSIDERING THE DAY FOR
EVERYBODY -- ANTENNA I'M
OBVIOUSLY HUMBLED AND HONORED TO
BE -- BE APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR
NEW SIM TO TO SERVE ON THIS.
THIS BOARD -- I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE JUST A FEW FOLKS IN
THE ROOM OF MY FELLOW BOARD
MEMBERS -- MEMBER BANKS MEMBER
SHINERS A MEMBER CHRIS OR IN THE
AUDIENCE.
BANKS SHINERS AND KRANZ.
IN THE AUDIENCE AND THEY'VE BEEN
REALLY WELCOMING AS I'VE TRIED
TO COME IN THIS AGENCY AND KIND
OF GET THE LAY OF THE LAND SO I
APPRECIATE ALL THE SUPPORT
THEY'VE GIVEN ME.
ALSO ARE AMAZING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR -- CHAU SCHOOL CUT
WHO'S TAKEN ON THE TASK OF
TRYING TO GET PROGRAM MIND ANY
SEND A FANTASTIC JOB.
IN RE THE STAFF WHO'S HERE AND
SOME OF THEM ARE ON WATCHING IT
ONLINE FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
THEY DO TO KEEP THE AGENCY GOING.
I WILL I JUST WANTED START WITH
MY FIRST DAY AT HER WHEN I WAS
IT.
GOING THROUGH MY OFFICE OPENED
UP A BOOK CASE SENATE AND IN THE
BOOKCASE WAS A BINDER.
ABOUT FOUR INCHES THICK I OPEN
IT UP AND IT WAS A SET OF
DECISIONS BY MARTY MORGANSTERN
WHO SERVED ON THE POR PER BOARD
IN NINETEEN IN THE EIGHTIES.
AND IT OCCURRED TO ME IN THAT
MOMENT -- AND AS I SAID BEFORE
YOU IS THAT THERE'S A LONG
LEGACY OF QUALITY INDIVIDUALS
HAVE SAT IN THE SEAT IN PR.
AND I HOPE TO MAINTAIN AND AND
CONTINUE THE WORK THAT THEY'VE
DONE.
NOT ONLY FOR ON BEHALF OF THE
EMPLOYEES WITH THE EMPLOYERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WITH THAT I HOPE I CAN MEET UP
WITH YOUR APPROVAL AND I'M OPEN
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I MISTER
MONNING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND I ALSO WANT TO CONGRATULATE
YOU ON THE APPOINTMENT IN. FOR
YOUR YEARS OF SERVICE FROM
FRONTLINE FIREFIGHTER.
TO REPRESENTING FIREFIGHTERS --
IN YOU BRING A LOT OF FIELD
EXPERIENCE SOME AND JUST BASIC
CARING AND COMPASSION TO THE
POSITION SO I CONGRATULATE YOU
AND THANK YOU WE HAD A GOOD
CONVERSATION -- JUST.
IN LOOKING AT WHAT YOU'RE MOVING
INTO ONE OF THE CONCERNS HAS
BEEN CASE LOG -- BACKLOG OF
CASES.
WHICH YEAR PERCEPTION OF THAT
CURRENT BACKLOG IN WHAT CAN BE
DONE TO MOVE THINGS FORWARD MORE
EXPEDITIOUSLY -- THANK YOU AND
AND OBVIOUSLY THAT'S A FRIEND OF
MINE FROM EVERYBODY AND I I CAN
TELL YOU IT WAS WHEN I WAS ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE TABLE
ASKING FOR MORE MONEY FOR PER
BURNED AND KIND OF YELLING
SCREAMING WHY ARE THEY MOVING
CASES MORE -- SO IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I'M VERY AWARE OF GOING IN
THIS POSITION I APPRECIATE ALL
THE SUPPORT THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR OF GETTING GIVEN ON
THE BUDGET -- THAT'S BEEN ABLE --
TO PROVIDERS MORE ATTORNEYS AT
EVERY LEVEL MORE MORE BORDER
VISORS -- I THINK -- THE BIG
CHALLENGE THAT WE FIND ON THE
CASELOAD IS IT'S JUST NOT
NECESSARY THE NUMBERS BUT THE
DYNAMICS OF THE NUMBERS SOME OF
THE CASES ARE VERY EASY TO
PROCESS THROUGH SOME OF THEM
TAKE A LONG TIME TO DO BECAUSE
YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT TO GET IT
RIGHT IT'S GOING. TO TAKE SOME
TIME TO DO IT AND SO EACH SIDE
OF THE THE THE COIN WHETHER
INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYEE O THE
EMPLOYER OR THE UNIONS ITSELF.
NEED TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO TO
GET A FAIR STRONG DELIVERED OF
DECISION SOME OF THAT TAKES SOME
TIME SO REALLY IT.
IT AS WE MOVE THROUGH THE
NUMBERS IT'S BEEN ONE OF THE
BIGGEST NUMBERS FOR PROBABLY
MOVE CASES THROUGH THIS YEAR --
THE BACKLOG IN THE FORTIES BUT
IT REALLY IS A QUESTION OF
RESOURCES AND IN EVERY SORT
ENOUGH RESOURCES SO WE CAN
PROCESS THE CASES.
I THINK ONE THING YOU ALSO
SHARED IS.
NOT ALL CASES REQUIRE SOME
DEMAND A LOT MORE -- RESOURCES
IN TIME IS THAT ACCURATE YEAH I
I THINK AND THE EXAMPLE USE NOT
TO GIVE ANY DETAILS AS WELL WELL
I'VE BEEN PERSON WORKING ON A
CASE -- SINCE MARCH -- AND WE'RE
NOT CLOSE TO ANY FINAL
DETERMINATION THEY UNDERSTAND
IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT QUESTION
ON BOTH SIDES.
AND IN THE PROBABLY UP ON APPEAL
SO YOU WANT TO GET THE RECORD
CORRECT AN IN DEPTH BECAUSE IT'S
GOING TO GO UP ON APPEAL AND BE
TAKING A LOOK AT SO YOU KNOW WE
COULD WE COULD COME TO A
DECISION A LOT FASTER.
BUT IT WOULDN'T BE FAIR TO ANY
PARTIES AS THEY MOVE THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND I THINK ONE THING I
FOUND IMPRESSIVE THAN YOU MIGHT
SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEES.
THE LOW PERCENTAGE OF CASES THAT
HAVE BEEN REVERSED ON APPEAL
WHICH I THINK'S STRONGLY TO THE
INTEGRITY OF THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS OF PER.
YEAH I THINK -- A IN A AGAIN IT
DOESN'T NECESSARY COME TO THE
LIGHT ABOUT THE CASES THAT HAVE
BEEN.
APPEALED -- WE HAVE A 97% TRACK
RECORD IN THE COURTS OF REALLY
ESPECIALLY RECENTLY LOOKED AT
AND SAY THAT WE ARE THE EXPERTS
ON THE SUBJECT MATTER WHEN IT
GETS UP ON APPEAL SO.
IT JUST GOES BACK TO THE ISSUE
OF THAT THE THE ALL THE BOARD
MEMBERS AND ALL THE STAFF A
PERVERT TAKE A JOB SERIOUS IN
AND WANT TO DO IT.
STRONG DELIVERS PROCESS BEFORE
THEY MAKE A DECISION IT'LL
THINKING AGAIN.
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
SERVICE PRECIADO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN LET ME GO TO YOU
SO THAT OUR OTHER SENATOR CAN
GET READ.
RE ADJUSTED ADVISING CENTER
MONIES QUESTIONS WERE RIGHT ON
THE MARK SO I DON'T REALLY HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD THE
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
SENATOR BATES ARE YOU -- I KNOW
I KNOW IT IS THESE AS AS I KNOW
THAT MISTER PAULSEN REMEMBERS
AND KNOWS THESE ARE BUSY BUSY
DAYS AND SO WITH THAT I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO YOU.
I I DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR YOU MISTER PAULSEN
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU.
BY DID US WITH THE DATE ON THE
PER DECISIONS THAT TOUR APPEAL
TO THE COURTS AND THAT WAS REAL
IMPORTANT THAT.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOU TODAY THANK YOU
SIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES LET ME
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
SEE WHO IS HERE IN SUPPORT.
I STEP UP GIVE YOUR NAME --
YOU'RE REPRESENTING AND I WILL
HAVE THE SECURITY REMOVE YOU
MISTER.
RIGHT.
BECAUSE I'M SURE I'M ABSOLUTELY
SURE THAT TO TOOT NICE LADIES IN
FRONT OF YOU DIDN'T CALLS THAT
PROBLEM.
AND YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT'S ON
THE RECORD NOW -- IT.
OKAY.
HI I'M KIDDING MICHAEL.
OKAY -- LET ME I'D IT WELCOME
YOU AND YOUR NAME WHO YOU
REPRESENT AND YOUR PUT YOUR
SUPPORT BRIEF COMMENTS THANK YOU.
BUT I'M PRO TEM BUT CHAIR
CHRISTY VELMA HERE ON THE OTHER
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
OF MY PREVIOUS COMMENT ABOUT
BEING A BABY LOBBYIST I WASN'T
EVEN A BABY LOBBYIST REALLY WHEN
I FIRST MET Là PAULSON ANSWERED
WORKING FOR THE ORGANIZATION.
US WE KIND OF GREW UP IN THIS
BUSINESS TOGETHER.
AND IT'S GOES WITHOUT SAYING
THAT I WOULD BE HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
WELL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BODY OF WORK THAT THIS MAN HOLDS
AND WHAT HE BRINGS TO THE PER.
SO WE URGE YOUR CONFIRMATION
TODAY.
THANK YOU AND ON BEHALF OF JOHN
WESLEY.
OKAY THERE ARE.
THANK YOU OKAY.
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS TERRY
BRENNAN ON BEHALF OF SCA YOU
CALIFORNIA -- IT'S BEEN MY
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH THAT LIEU
FIGHTING ON BEHALF OF WORKING
MEN AND WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
A VERY LONG TIME INCLUDING.
FIGHTING FOR MORE FUNDING FOR
THE PER BOARD DAY AND DEALING
WITH THEIR PACK LOCK I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO CALLING AND YELLING
AT HIM DIRECTLY ABOUT THE
BACKLOG PURRS.
PER BROTHER -- WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF HIS CONFIRMATION.
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE BUT ALSO WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES --
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS I COULD
SAY ABOUT LOOK PAULSON -- BUT HE
IS A WONDERFUL WONDERFUL
COMMITTED -- ADVOCATE FOR HIS
MEMBERS FOR HIS -- FOR WORKERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- AS
A YOUNG PERSON WHO TOOK OVER --
ASKED ME CALIFORNIA ALWAYS
APPRECIATED HIS CANDOR -- IS IN
SIGHT -- AND EVEN THOUGH WE WERE
ALWAYS SEEING EYE TO EYE ON
ISSUES -- WHEN WHEN WE DIDN'T HE
ALWAYS RESPOND WITH REASON AND
LOGIC AND I THINK THAT THAT IS
IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF PURPOSE --
IS IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF
WORKERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO DEPEND ON PER BY
AND I AM GRATEFUL -- THAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERING HIS
CONFIRMATION THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO A TO APPOINT HIM UP TO
THIS ROLE SO.
WOULD URGES ARE CONFIRMATIONS
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME MA'AM CHAIR AND CENTERS
COULD BE PRESIDING WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS WE
COULDN'T ACTUALLY THINK OF A
MORE.
PERFECT PERSON FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT LIEU HAS.
YOU KNOW EXPERIENCE FROM THE
RANK AND FILE TO REPRESENTING TO
ACTUALLY PRESENTING BEFORE THE
PER HE'S DONE IT ALL HE KNOWS A
LOT AND AN IMPART THAT WISDOM
ON TO THE BOARD AND I THINK FOR
THAT REASON ALONE HE WOULD BE
ABSOLUTELY.
WONDERFUL FOR THIS POSITION SO
WE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M SURE MEMBERS THE BAKER WITH
THEIR AND READ MISSES HIS FOR
THE PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT.
IN ADDITION TO MARTY MORGANSTERN
BEING A FORMER BOARD MEMBER MY
FATHER WAS A FORMER BOARD MEMBER.
AND MY FATHER IN LIEU HAVE SOME
SIMILAR BACKGROUNDS I THINK THAT
BACKGROUND WILL SOON FLEW WELL
AT THIS POSITION AND DO A GREAT
JOB WITH SUPPORTERS CONFIRMATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I WENT IN TURN MEMBERS CAITLIN
VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION VERY PLEASED TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT A
POSSUM FOR THIS POSITION.
OUR PURPOSE SERVES AN ESSENTIAL
ROLE FOR THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES OF
CALIFORNIA -- WHO BETTER THAN
SOMEONE WHO ADVOCATED?
NOT ONLY FOR HIS OWN MEMBERS
WHICH I THINK EVERYONE KNOWS HIM
FOR BUT ALSO AS A VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION FOR THE BEST
INTERESTS OF ALL WORKING PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND REALLY TRYING TO WORK TOWARD
A FAIR ECONOMY WITH GOOD JOBS
I'M SOMEONE WHO SEES THAT BIG
PICTURE AND SEES THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE LABOR RELATIONS ROLE --
ACT WERE VERY HAPPY TO HAVE --
DID THAT HE'S BEEN APPOINTED AND
PLACE IT BEHIND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MADAM PROTON OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
ABOVE TO RECALL ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE COLUSA PERMISSION
ORGANIZATIONS YEAR C. W. AND THE
CALIFORNIA CONNECTORS SO SHE
SHOULD IN SUPPORT OF THE
NOMINATION CONFIRMATION.
THE BUT AS AS A MEMBERS CAMINO
PURBA A CAUSE I JUDICIAL BODY
MAKES IMPORTANT DECISIONS ABOUT
PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOOD.
I THINK THE CHARACTERISTICS JUNE
CONNECTICUT ON ON THIS POSITION.
IS THAT INTEGRITY JUDGMENT AND
TEMPERAMENT.
THE THREE JUST CRIED WHEN YOU'RE
MAKING CANCERS AND I THINK THIS
NOMINEE.
CERTAINLY FITS THE BILL AND ALL
THOSE MY LAST COUPLE WITH THIS --
ONE OF THE GREAT PLEASURES THAT
WE HAVEN'T IN THIS JOB HE WAS
LEGISLATORS MUSCLES OF FORMERLY
CENTER.
YOU GET TO MEET SOME INCREDIBLE
PEOPLE YOU GET TO FORGE SOME
TREMENDOUS LIFELONG FRIENDSHIPS
I'M VERY PROUD OF CAL MR PAULSON
IS ONE OF MY FRIENDS -- AND AND
AND I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR MAKE AN APPOINTMENT
AND I WANNA.
IN ADVANCE THANK YOU FOR
CONFIRMING THE NOMINATION THANK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS J'AI
SUPPRESS IT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION --
DOES NOT MATCH WHAT I COULD ADD
TO THE PREVIOUS TESTIMONIES --
OTHER THAN TO SAY THAT I'VE
BECAUSE WE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING.
WITH MISTER PAULSEN IN A NUMBER
OF ACT DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES AND
TO BE ABLE TO WATCH HIM.
DEAL WITH DIFFICULT SITUATION
AND TO MAINTAIN THE CALMNESS IN
A ROOM TO MAKE A DECISION AS ONE
OF THE KEY BENEFITS I THINK.
HAVING HIM OF THE PURPORT TO
ADDRESS A LOT OF TOUGH ISSUES
ARE GOING TO BE ESSENTIAL FOR
THE STATE.
WE ARE HAPPY TO BE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PENSION
MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH THEIR AND
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HYPER PATROLMAN IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS.
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
NOMINATION AND CONFIRMATION OF
LIEU PAULSON WE'VE ALL WORKED
WITH HIM FOR MANY YEARS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM --
IN HIS BECAUSE I RETIREMENT ON
THE PER BOARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON NANCY VARIAS WITH
SEIU LOCALONE THOUSAND
REPRESENTING NINETY SIX THOUSAND
STATE EMPLOYEES LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND HAS ALWAYS HAD A REALLY
GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH
FIREFIGHTERS AND ESPECIALLY WITH
LOU AND ITHINK THAT THAT WILL
CONTINUE WHEN.
YOU ARE PERMITS AND ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL OF LIEU ALSO ONE
OF MY MENTORS A LOWER PRICE
DOESN'T KNOW IT AND I DIDN'T
LEARN THE SAME THINGS THAT I DID
FROM THE PREVIOUS CAN.
DEFINE.
THANK YOU.
LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE -- HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN.
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING I WE'RE
GOING TO CALL THE ROLL BUT
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT -- I KNOW
THIS IS NOT AN EASY JOB ACTUALLY.
BUT WE APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE WILLING TO DO IT AND
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR THE
APPOINTMENT.
MADAM SECRETARY.
SENATORS BATES.
IT'S ON MY MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROTH.
ROUGH I WILL.
WILK AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE
THAT IS UNANIMOUS
CONGRATULATIONS.
LET ME.
OPEN THE ROLE ON GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
FOR ITEM A GENEVIEVE SURE ROMA.
SENATOR ROTH ROTH HI.
THAT'S FOUR ONE THANK YOU THAT
IS A FOUR ONE VOTE SO THAT IF.
SHE IS CONFIRMED.
A LET ME OPEN THE ROLE ON ITEM
ONE B. MONA PASCAL ROGERS
SENATORS BATES.
I ROUGH ROUGH FIVE FIVE ZERO
THAT IS A FIVE ZERO THAT
CONFIRMATION IS DONE AND THAT.
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS ARE
SENATE ROTH DID YOU WANT TO SAY
ANYTHING I WE KNOW I I MADE SURE
THAT EVERYONE HERE KNEW THAT YOU
WERE.
ABSOLUTELY AT A DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE DO AND HARD BUDGET
WORK SO -- AND NO NO WORRIES
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IF YOU
NEEDED TO MAKE A COMMENT WITH
THAT WE WILL ADJOURN INTO.
EXECUTIVE SESSION